سوسات الصحيه ضبطها عددا من الشهادات التي
اصدرتها الجامعه السودانيه الوهميه قبل ان
يتم كشف وهميه هذه الاكاديميه الاسبوع
الماضي مشيره الى ان اصحاب هذه الشهادات
لم يتمكنوا من اجتياز معايير الهيئه في
التدقيق
بعد اسبوع من الجدل الذي اثاره خبر القاء
القبض على رئيس جامعه سودانيه وهميه خرجت
خلال نحو عشر سنوات الاف الطلاب بمنحهم
شهادات مزوره من كليات منها التمريض
والهندسه والصيدله وغيرها جدلا قديم جديد
يعود حول الشهادات الوهميه وهل لاصحابها
وجود على راس العمل في السعوديه التي دخلت
حربا لا تزال قائمه ضد الشهادات المزوره
واصحابها منذ سنوات الهيئه السعوديه
للتخصصات الصحيه اكدت انها ضبطت عددا من
الشهادات التي اصدرتها الجامعه السودانيه
الوهميه حتى قبل ان يتم اكتشافه وهميتها
لكن اصحاب هذه الشهادات لم يتمكنوا من
اجتياز معايير الهيئه في التدقيق مؤكده
انها تتبع اجراءات دقيقه في التصنيف
والتسجيل تمنع دخول غير المؤهلين للقطاع
الصحي خصوصا القادمين من الخارج بحسب
الهيئه الهيئه واشاره ايضا الى ان اجراءات
في قوى التاكد من الشهادات تخضع للتدقيق
قبل قدوم الممارس الصحي للعمل حيث يتم
التاكد من صحه الشهادات قبل الشروع في
تقديم طلبات التصنيف ورغم ان الحرب على
الشهادات المزوره بدات بمجهودات فرديه عبر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي منذ سنوات الا
انها شهدت في الاعوام الاخيره قبضه كبيره
من ناحيه الانظمه والقوانين التي تم فرضها
ومنها الاختبارات المهنيه حيث يتوجب على
الراغبين من خارج السعوديه بالعمل
اجتيازها خصوصا في هذه التخصصات الصحيه
والهندسيه والفنيه ما ضيق الخناقه على
حملها هذه الشهاده